Umbra's my name is fear ba what's going
on
alright but yeah I don't even know where
Harris but when this freaking bag forage
cattle version - alright
and now wow the last episode that else
that was something all right
I'm just gonna oddish nothing here
really you battle sites [ __ ] hate you
battles get out of my house pals - mr.
Jack no you can say miss yeah yeah
thanks Betty your true Brock you know I
didn't talk to that van for anything
Jesse you know like I'm not traitor or
anything yeah I trust you
right I'll skip - I like boxes you ruin
my life - are you doing my staircase
boxing all right okay I'm not sure where
I'm gonna go actually not sure or not I
know I know we forget ha buddy how you
doing bro that's a good day hey what is
this tinderboxes Laden and I'm not
worried slide you try that
Hamid I spit all of my screen but get
out of here okay
got them traitor barrels hate rap get
what [ __ ] em I can't go here no I don't
this is out let's recap where the [ __ ]
am I going I have a crowbar now hello
my only exits luck oh I can t oh yeah I
had a crowbar door slams shut I want
great for to plan all right I get it I
get it
all right let's do an MLG jump let's do
the MLG Java crap I can't let's do try
the MLG right ah didn't work but not yet
don't think we're gonna go back there
actually about all right got damage so
dark
what are you doing here right you were
hiding from me weren't you mister
whether there's a locked door that I can
open but I'm not sure what it is this
battles every way are they hiding
always hiding all right where's the door
where door buddy stupid barrels no I'm
Susan I pick up the crowbar here so that
means I've kind of ha ha mr. chair
you know I know what the Pacers I'm not
gonna tell you why not cuz I missed you
that's why I do I'm a serious and [ __ ]
okay fine no it's not
didn't say [ __ ] what are you talking
about Daniel get down to put that in
your brush all right fine okay fine I'm
so confused
I don't understand the dolls will it
shut probably won't open Isaac wish da I
don't understand
oh oh oh I know I know I know I need mr.
box and I'm paying do you need me at
really mr. Bach whatever why we're
you're gonna put you here buddy all
right good all right let's go always
pooper
oh [ __ ] he's always always got a
breakdown I always got a break boys wait
a microbe argon oh there we go
all right [ __ ] yeah yeah all right what
was that
[Music]
that is my Santa Persian thank you very
much all right
tree monsters I'm gonna close the door I
don't even know why I got there I got
nothing from that place
this is stupid statues I don't gesture
where's the fauna barrels everywhere you
disgust me
I detest you alright maybe now we
actually go here hopefully no so we can
that's great
I feel good feel good about that yeah
but I got the freaking crowbars what do
you want from me I'm obviously missing
something I don't know what I'm missing
I don't get it I'm crying [ __ ] on it
I don't need it maybe I missed something
here I don't you have a lot of oil nope
I don't [ __ ] rate
alright box now mate tell me where it is
this is a pop-up don't you break
yourself this is this is humour seducers
that wasn't even Jesus is Christ
I wasn't even break [ __ ] I gotta break
all this [ __ ] right stuff that's what
you get
man it's the thing that I need I don't
know
a min here hello now where's the thing
room tell me tell me
Brum Brum anything
[ __ ] you Brown okay now I'm a surgeon ah
well I got back I get back I get back I
get back to a wash me long you back get
back get back to wait double pumper you
yeah hop in it you're back alright shut
up sure sure so why do you want from me
what am I missing
no a simple is impossible I don't get it
I don't get it
I quite frankly don't QT fine I'll go
back once again Jesus Christ I'm out of
oil this is bad
alright fine excuse mr. box gym and jump
yes
ah man that was awesome Oh God is so
light
all right fine I got this I mean I
hadn't worse nation let's just go here
then I guess wow this is what we stopped
dead maybe I missed something yet I
don't even know
but you pals stop doing that some oil
would be [ __ ] great right now huh mr.
carpet what are you doing mr. carpet why
are you talking to me I don't get it
what I do I can't go here I don't
understand
I'd really really really really really
really really really I don't get it they
don't themselves I'm an idiot I'm an
idiot I can't believe I missed this all
right you just gotta move the freakin
table ah so strong so strong it was he
barrel is he bowing near that would go
that's the key it does to keep that who
you are looking for
wee wee wee wee with that serious it
kills my wants to say I'm trying to say
that we will be ah count them barrels
all right
so nice trying go yeah I don't trust
this room yeah look at things it is
pretty ha ha
okay tinderbox for me Jesus you can oh
mr. carpet can you do it okay mr. chair
big big make it up mr. Schaffer chairman
activated poop up okay I'm gonna try
airboat
I credit chair mr. Chou don't think it
working okay how did you know just be
crappy name holy [ __ ]
chair won't work I got a lion Anna Anna
and man man I told you feeding a freakin
child you I'm Marilyn times but you
never listen and now what he did
hey why aren't you happy we can be
broached forever not bt we could just be
like Shamu activated bump over the
rainbow oh my - alright
I thought you're looking at that example
I don't care wait why did I pick up
I didn't pick up [ __ ] I forgot the lever
I forgot to lever oh well 11 no that's
your mid one that we got all right I'll
just nuts not I maybe now I can go a
stick and go holy [ __ ]
did I find a secret exit I found a
secret exit I didn't even house here all
along and you were there I'm gonna go
over here and yeah yeah alright I was
here yeah but you know I don't listen
alright let's go to map number 200 what
happens in the bedroom stays on that I'm
hilarious Jesus Christ
alright
but this year am i doing at the stairs I
don't understand
but it's the father it's a bad time he
shows that oh you're a Nazi for
knowledge yeah
wait I thought I saw antenna box that's
mine I clean that [ __ ] that claim that
[ __ ] to read here sandy point I don't
care I don't care
no where's father you should be here
makes up wait let's just move this
before we do something no open bro bro
your problem
don't know
all right fine I don't care I don't care
I don't care
Jesus words Tufano I won't tell you
Jesus Christ where's the fauna
ah where's the photo I don't get it I
don't get II crazy stop being like Jesus
Christ did you talk to him with your
shirt that's the bone that's a damn fine
bone
yep but that super fascinating motor
that we got what I need fun ki do
subpoenas hate finding keys supplying
fighting cheese everywhere thank GL
thank you there I don't even know
anymore
hey I'm a maybe I'm not a piano
no it's not that who touched my wall I
did that I didn't do that
no nothing in the bookshelves and where
it's breaking key
[Music]
I have no luck finding [ __ ] today out I
mean why won't you open
[Music]
okay let's touch it without burning our
fingers oh yeah it's crazy that all
right son
oh come on I have no life today all
right that one oh wait maybe it's for
the stupid drawer no now you either all
right maybe it's for the stupid mr.
Sherlock I don't know
[Music]
yep there we got backs yeah yeah
Scully are you hiding here what are you
pity there's nothing to see it I
promised her you can go back what are
you hiding Humphrey for me buddy
I mean it's coming what is that oh oh
that was that I have no I bear all right
I want to call it a short key of course
it's no no no no no Lola I didn't do
anything I just went here and I was like
I'm gonna up into this chest this is
okay we got a copper key
we got a friggin cutout anyone in here
okay all right oh you thought oh all
right let's go here let's just go that's
a pump Wheatley hi hello
I need in my eyes all right no problem
look who's that okay all right yes hello
speedy I waited a long time for you
[Music]